how do you feel about this week because
i can tell you this entire auditorium
was moved on several different levels
watching mom what'd you think about it i
thought it was amazing because mom
she's usually like around the house a
lot
not doing too much but
and i'm really happy that she got out it
was a big shift i'm like right i'm
worried about all of the dance stuff and
like classes and stuff like that and now
she getting a third place tie i thought
that was amazing
also a time for third place with 28
points selma
[Music]
[Applause]
she rocked it tonight selma how do you
feel it was incredible to have a dance
you know it really is this was a time of
learning to
you know really build my stamina i was
doing great um
really in great recovery
after stem cell transplant bone marrow
and i needed to find a way i realized i
was like kind of going backwards a
little bit not really getting myself
moving as much and my son is like so
active and i want to be there well
sometimes
but actually i have we have a little
gripe about that actually but i'd like
him to be more active and i was like
well i better build my stamina
and this was an incredible opportunity
it just felt right and i'm so grateful
i'm with sasha and i had that dance and
he's you know he was in a lot of pain
today and he rushed off to get something
taken care of so i have this guy
but i love sasha i love this dance and
it was an incredible experience now you
mentioned that you've doubted yourself
before
how do you feel about doubting yourself
ever after this evening
i'm
i'm gonna learn to settle into just
gratitude and being kind to myself
because everyone has been so kind to me
and this feels so good to move
it feels so good to gain strength and
i'm
i'm just truly truly grateful and
enjoying this so much you had also said
your cane was like a dance partner and
you passed off your cane and went to
your dance partner and you took all of
us and scooped us up and collectively
put us in your heart in that moment what
does that mean to you how important is
that
i mean it means everything because
you know i do i do i am a vulnerable
person now out here um you know with
some differences i have or weakness and
i really never thought i would be able
to dance like with both my feet one in
and it and and it just means so much to
be able to
lean on someone for my balance like to
really find a frame and to know that i
could go from what i'm used to or
holding my son
to have sasha
and like moving
i just love it it's such joy it's such
joy and i hope
i just hope that we can all see that
like we can do things out of our comfort
zone it might not look like everybody
else but it's still an incredible
feeling you are such an inspiration and
so moving and so effective with your
goal out there it is incredible and it
makes us want to stand up and yell from
mountaintops about anything we haven't
tried or said yes to in our lives i love
it and we should we should try more we
we should embrace people that are trying
and willing to teach us and
we need each other i need you i need us
i need him i want us to embrace each
other and so gosh am i lucky and i am
the father of a seven-year-old and i
will say the lesson that you're
displaying for this handsome young
fellow here
and to all these young people out there
that are watching you is profound you
have no idea the effect that you're
going to have on so many people by doing
it makes me feel good
selma and i are actually neighbors and i
am so pumped that she's my partner sasha
lives close to you how important was
that in the factoring all this together
oh gosh you know i just thought
there was no way i would be able to keep
my calm enough to have control of my
body
and just knowing sasha a little bit um
he's seen me blowing my leaves in the
front yard and like being ridiculous and
every year i'm like no no no i don't
dance you don't understand and i have
some glitches
but then i we just kind of stood next to
each other and he said you know i'm not
i'm not gonna let you go
and i said wow no one's ever said that
to me before so i'm gonna go
you're perfect yeah you're perfect young
man it's nice to meet you thank you wait
one more thing i just want to say this
is my grandma's favorite channel so
shout out to my grandma oh my god for
sure for sure
we love you grandma
[Music]